ahora digamos que la compañía a bs de
quiere lanzar unos nuevos medicamentos y
su precio de la acción que actualmente
anda como alrededor de los 50 dólares y
estás convencido de la aprobación de los
medicamentos y entonces crees que pueden
llegar a subir el precio de la acción
pues éstas estarían vendiendo como pan
caliente y bien por otro lado también
digamos que hay una acción posible a la
baja digamos que son unos tanques que
andan alrededor de los 5 o 10 dólares
por acción así que si te gustaría
asegurar alguna cantidad después de
todas estas especulaciones y que por
cierto no siempre son tan recomendables
pero bueno siempre es más complicado en
la realidad a cómo se ve en un simple
ejemplo como este pero bien la manera de
poder comparar estas acciones es con una
opción de compra y una opción de venta
siendo que la opción de venta nos daría
un beneficio con la acción que tiende a
bajar como la de los tanques y luego la
opción de compra nos aportaría dinero si
las acciones tienden a subir como en el
caso de los medicamentos y en este
último ejemplo en el caso de la acción
de las alzas si tienden a bajar pues
llega al punto en donde se encuentran
con el de las bajas que llegan
es casi cero y conforme pase esto pues
ya no ejerce esta opción de compra es
preferible mejor ejercer tu opción de
venta pues puedes llegar a comprar esas
acciones casi en cero y después ejercer
tu opción de venta en 50 dólares pues
estamos hablando del derecho de vender a
ese precio pero hablamos de esta
combinación de la expiración y si la
opción llega a bajar tanto que ya no
tiene valor pues ya no ejercemos nuestra
opción de compra entonces de haber
estado en un precio de venta de 50
dólares esto cada vez se va haciendo
menor también claro está la otra parte
si los precios pasan de los 50 alguien
no te conviene ejercer tu opción de
venta lo que sí te conviene en este caso
sería ejercer la opción de compra pues
si la acción vale en el mercado 60
dólares en expiración después la opción
de compra valdrá 10 dólares o sea breeze
ganó 10 dólares pues obtuviste el
derecho de comprar algo que está en 60
en 50 así que el diagrama de compra se
vería de esta forma lo que dibuje justo
aquí si pensamos en el plus que nos da
tener la opción de compra y la opción de
venta es bueno pero si observas no sirve
de mucho si los precios de las acciones
no varían mucho entre altas y va
si no pasan de los 80 dólares esto no
tendrá en realidad ningún valor pero si
hay grandes movimientos a la izquierda
oa la derecha de esta tajada que deja lo
escribo aquí arriba esto es cuando
compra si ejerces la opción de venta o
ejercer la opción de compra me refiero a
la combinación compraventa para
movimientos muy volátiles y estos 10
dólares que acabó encerrado en la opción
de complexión de venta es el costo para
hallarlos al diagrama de pérdidas y
ganancias pero en este caso el diagrama
se desliza a 20 dólares hacia abajo
porque 20 pues estás pagando 10 dólares
para entrar a la opción de venta y 10
dólares para entrar a la opción de
compra ahora viéndolo por el lado de la
opción de venta aunque nos haya generado
50 dólares por así decirlo se le tienen
que debe restar los 20 de ambas opciones
así que sólo habríamos ganado 30 dólares
y si en un caso muy particular que
ninguna opción tuviera ningún movimiento
y no quisiéramos ejercerlas pues
simplemente dibujamos aquí el puntito de
los menos 20 dólares y aquí va bajando
llega a los 50 dólares y la horcajada
comienza a subir en este caso es cuando
nos conviene ejercer la opción de compra
y pues bueno así luce nuestro diagrama
en el caso de pérdidas y ganancias como
lo había mencionado anteriormente esto
ayuda a grandes movimientos pero bueno
regresando a lo de los medicamentos si
se realizarán las las necesarias
estadísticas y estas fueran publicadas
antes de la fecha de vencimiento de las
opciones y éstas se fueran por debajo de
esta área se van por debajo de los 30
dólares hoy llegarán a subir tanto como
un máximo de 70 dólares se observa aquí
un gran movimiento y después de este
recorrido a lo largo de la horcajada
compra-venta se logrará obtener bastante
dinero